this has happened before and it's happening
again.
And in fact, we've covered this before on
actual election days.
Video has caught an electronic voting machine
switching votes and we now have at least three
reports of this happening and at least two
different Mississippi counties based on the
latest information.
And this could still change a, this was the
republican gubernatorial primary runoff.
We have one video of it for you posted to
Facebook by Sally Kate Walker, which shows
a man attempting to vote for bill Waller and
the machine selecting instead Tate Reeves
multiple times as the person taps the screen.
So a few things here.
This particular video is from the Burgess
voting precinct in Oxford.
And the same machines that are in use there
are in use in lots of the state of Mississippi.
The Secretary of State's office has put out
a statement saying they're aware of the issue
and they dispatched a technician as soon as
they were told about it.
Uh, this was a TSX machine.
It's owned by the county.
It was tested by local officials to machines
in Calhoun county have reportedly shown similar
votes switching behavior.
So, okay, this is a republican gubernatorial,
primary runoff.
They're fixing it.
What happens if this takes place on presidential
election day in November of 2020 when turnout
is higher, when the stakes are, yes, they
are higher.
Even though of course we want every election
to be secure.
When one precinct or a group of precincts
could conceivably turn a state and one state
could conceivably decide the presidential
election, what do you do now?
As of right now, there's no reason to think
that this is foul play.
Uh, this is most likely the screen being miscalibrated.
So when you tap on a part of the screen, it's
interpreted as you tapping on a different
part of the screen.
It's simple enough, but it's potentially 110%
chaotic on election day.
If one wanted to manipulate an election, you
only need to interfere with some portion of
the machines in some portion of precincts
in just one or two states.
And you can hypothetically turn the results
of a presidential election.
And this is where the left and right are truly
different.
I talk so many times on the show about there's
lots of areas where left and right are basically
the same perpetuating the status quo.
There are other areas, a are areas where Democrats
and are very different when it comes to, uh,
sexual harassment by people within their party.
Democrats and Republicans are very different
when it comes to net neutrality.
Democrats and Republicans are very differently.
Republicans have made it clear for more than
a decade now.
They are simply not super concerned with election
interference, election tampering, voter suppression,
et Cetera.
As long as their candidate wins and they understand
that a lot of this stuff helps the Republican
over the Democrat helps the more conservative
Republican over the more moderate Republican
within Republican primaries.
But in principle, they don't care as long
as they benefit from it in some way, shape
or form.
The left.
On the other hand, we just want 100% secure
elections.
We want everyone who wants to vote and attempts
to vote to have their vote counted.
And the reality is of course that the left
benefits from greater turnout and more votes
being counted because the country has moved
to the left.
There is no, you know the right will say,
will you guys just want more people to vote
because it helps you.
That's right.
I want the highest level of participation
in the system that we have with the understanding
that the will of the people will be most accurately
reflected when as many people as possible
actually go out and vote.
When the right hears about this stuff, they
say, well both sides do it.
Even when it's not totally clear that something
is actually being done.
And when you zoom out it is far more red states
that have the electronic voting machines with
no paper trail, which if one wanted to tamper
with an election through the voting machines
that have no paper trail, it would be a really
great place to start.
So this is again just another one of the many
anecdotes of this taking place.
It's not presidential election day, but we
all understand the risk here, or at least
we should understand the risk here.
What's the next step with these particular
voting machines?
I don't know, but these types of voting machines
are in use in a lot of the United States.